[Music]
cattle better known to most a sirloin
brisket t-bone short rib or simply beef
but what you see in the meat aisle is
only part of the animal
for perspective about 60% is harvested
for food the other 40% ends up in places
like lipstick and jet fuel let's start
with one of the most ubiquitous parts
the fat the fat that doesn't end up at
the butchers is rendered into a product
called tallow fatty acids in the towel
Oh give it a slick oily consistency
which adds to the texture in some body
creams Cosmetics soaps and toothpaste
they're also a lubricant in antifreeze
hydraulic brake fluids and jet engines
and are even being tested as a biofuel
for planes in the US Air Force but
powering planes is just the beginning we
also rely on cattle for certain
life-saving medicines like insulin
bovine insulin is nearly identical to
humans so the cow pancreas is often used
to make insulin injections for diabetics
likewise the adrenal glands are used in
certain steroid drugs cartilage helps
make medicine for people who suffer from
osteoarthritis and the lungs are used in
blood thinners like heparin medicine
aside we even use cattle leftovers in
plastic surgery collagen from the hide
is purified and injected into the face
for a younger look but it turns out that
plastic surgery isn't the most common
use for collagen that title goes to
gelatin which is made from boiling cow
bones and hide gelatin gives that
distinctive gummy texture to foods like
certain marshmallows caramels gummies
and jams there are more than 700 and
27,000 beef farms in the u.s. that
slaughter roughly 30 million cattle each
year while we usually think about the
meat that ends up on the grill the parts
we ignore are present throughout our
everyday lives
[Music]